y como resultado,
cuando todos los ojos están puestos en nosotros,
a veces fallamos nuestro rendimiento
Por supuesto, la pregunta es, "¿por qué?".
Mi experiencia en el campo de juego
y en otras facetas importantes de mi vida
me llevó al campo de la ciencia cognitiva.
Quise saber cómo podríamos alcanzar nuestro potencial ilimitado
Quise entender cómo podríamos usar nuestro conocimiento
de la mente y del cerebro
para encontrar herramientas psicológicas que nos ayudaran a rendir al máximo.
Entonces, ¿por qué sucede?
¿Por qué a veces fallamos en lo que somos capaces de hacer
cuando hay presión?
No es sorprendente escuchar que en situaciones estresantes, nos preocupamos.
Nos preocupamos por la situación,
las consecuencias,
lo que otros pensarán de nosotros.
Pero lo que es sorprendente es que a menudo lo hacemos a nuestro modo
porque nuestras preocupaciones nos empujan a concentrarnos demasiado.
Exacto.
Prestamos mucha atención a lo que estamos haciendo.
Cuando estamos preocupados por hacer el mejor rendimiento,
a menudo intentamos y controlamos aspectos de lo que estamos haciendo
que serían mejor dejar en piloto automático,
fuera de la conciencia.
Y como resultado,
nos equivocamos.
Piensen en una situación donde arrastran los pies por las escaleras.
¿Qué pasaría si les pidiera
que pensaran en lo que hacen con su rodilla
mientras haces lo otro?
Hay una gran posibilidad de que se cayeran de bruces.
Como humanos solo tenemos la habilidad de prestar mucha atención a una cosa.
Por eso, por cierto,
no es buena idea conducir y hablar por el teléfono.
Y bajo presión,
cuando nos preocupa hacer todo lo mejor posible,
podemos intentar controlar aspectos de lo que estamos haciendo
que deberían quedarse fuera del control consciente.
El resultado final es que nos equivocamos.
Mi equipo y yo hemos investigado este fenómeno de exceso de atención,
y lo llamamos parálisis por análisis.
En un estudio pedimos a los jugadores de fútbol de la universidad
que regatearan un balón de fútbol
y que prestaran atención a un aspecto de su actuación
que de otra forma no atenderían.
Les pedimos que prestaran atención
en qué lado del pie estaba en contacto con la pelota.
Nos fijamos en que el rendimiento fue mas lento y más propenso a errores
al fijar su atención en los detalles paso por paso
de lo que hacían.
Cuando la presión está activa,
a menudo nos preocupamos por actuar lo mejor posible
y como resultado controlamos lo que estamos haciendo
forzando nuestro mejor rendimiento.
El resultado final es que nos equivocamos.
En baloncesto,
"inconsciente" se usa para describir a un tirador que no puede fallar.
Y la estrella de San Antonio Spurs Tim Duncan dijo:
"Cuando tienes que parar y pensar, es cuando te equivocas".
En baile el gran coreógrafo George Balanchine
solía insistir a sus bailarines:
"No piensen, solo háganlo".
Cuando hay presión,
cuando queremos poner nuestro mejor pie adelante,
algo irónico,
a menudo intentamos controlar qué hacemos empeorando el rendimiento.
Así que, ¿qué hacemos?
Sabiendo que tenemos esta atención hiperactiva,
¿cómo nos aseguramos de hacerlo lo mejor posible?
Mucho de ésto se reduce a la corteza prefrontal,
esa parte frontal de nuestro cerebro situada sobre los ojos
que normalmente nos ayuda a enfocarnos de manera positiva,
a menudo se centra más en las peores cosas.
Y ¿cómo lo desengachamos?
Algo tan simple como cantar una canción,
o prestar atención al dedo meñique,
como se rumoreaba que hacía el golfista Jack Nicklaus,
puede ayudar a olvidarnos de esos molestos detalles.
También es cierto que practicamos en condiciones
bajo las que vamos a actuar.
Cerrando al brecha entre el entrenamiento y la competencia,
puede ayudarnos con esa sensación de que nos están mirando.
Esto también pasa fuera del campo.
Si se están preparando para un examen
o preparándose para una charla,
uno podría tener un poco de presión asociada a ello.
(Risas)
Acostumbrarse a los tipos de situaciones a los que uno se enfrenta,
importa.
Cuando estás haciendo un examen, cierra el libro,
hay que practicar
recuperando la respuesta de la memoria en situaciones temporalizadas,
y cuando uno debe dar una charla,
hay que practicar ante otros.
Si no pueden encontrar a nadie que les escuche,
practiquen ante una cámara de vídeo o incluso en un espejo.
La habilidad de acostumbrarnos a lo que se siente puede marcar la diferencia
en si fallamos o prosperamos.
Hemos averiguado formas de deshacerse de esas preocupaciones molestas
y dudas sobre sí mismo que tienden a asomarse en situaciones estresantes.
Los investigadores han demostrado que anotando sus pensamientos y preocupaciones
antes de una situación estresante,
puede ayudar a descargarlos de la mente.
Es menos probable que aparezcan el momento.
Es como cuando uno se despierta en medio de la noche
y está preocupado por lo que tiene que hacer al día siguiente,
uno piensa en todo lo que tienes que hacer
y lo anota. Y después puede volver a dormir.
Apuntando esos pensamientos en papel,
hace menos probable que aparezcan y nos distraigan en el momento.
El resultado final es poder rendir mejor, cuando más lo necesiten.
Hasta ahora,
he hablado sobre lo que sucede cuando nos ponemos límites
y algún consejo que podemos usar para ayudar a mejorar nuestro potencial.
Pero es importante recordar
que no es solo nuestro propio ser
el que puede poner limites y que puede funcionar mal.
El entorno tiene el efecto de bloqueamos o alentarnos.
Nuestros padres, profesores, entrenadores, jefes, todos influyen
poniendo o no nuestro mejor esfuerzo cuando se necesita.
Tomemos las matemáticas como ejemplo.
Eso es, lo dije:
Matemáticas.
Mucha gente dice angustiarse o estar ansioso con las matemáticas,
ya sea haciendo una prueba o incluso calculando la propina de la cuenta,
cuando sus amigos inteligentes están mirando.
Y es bastante aceptado socialmente
hablar de bloquearse o de tener un bajo rendimiento en matemáticas.
No se escucha a personas con formación superior hablando del hecho,
o alardeando de no ser buenos lectores.
Pero sí se escucha a gente todo el tiempo
fanfarroneando de lo malos que son en matemáticas.
Y desafortunadamente,
en EE. UU. esta tendencia es mayor entre niñas y mujeres
que entre niños y hombres.
Mi equipo de investigación y yo hemos intentado entender
de dónde viene este miedo a las matemáticas,
y hemos observado el interior del cerebro
usando imágenes de resonancia magnética funcional
de gente a la que le preocupan las matemáticas.
Hemos demostrado que la fobia a las matemáticas
se correlaciona con una sensación visceral concreta
como el dolor,
por lo que tenemos todo el derecho de sentirnos ansiosos.
De hecho, cuando la gente está inquieta por las matemáticas
tan solo preparándose para hacer la prueba,
sin ni siquiera haciéndola, solo preparándosela,
las áreas del cerebro implicadas en la respuesta al dolor neural están activas
Cuando decimos que las matemáticas son dolorosas,
hay algo de verdad para algunas personas.
Pero, ¿de dónde viene esa ansiedad matemática?
La ansiedad matemática es contagiosa.
Cuando a los adultos les preocupan las matemáticas,
los niños de alrededor empiezan a preocuparse también
Tan jóvenes como los de primer grado
cuando los niños están en la clase
con profesores preocupados por su propia capacidad matemática,
esos niños aprenden menos a lo largo del año escolar.
Y ésto resulta que es más frecuente en niñas que en niños.
A esa temprana edad,
los pequeños tienen a imitar a los adultos del mismo sexo.
y al menos en EE. UU.
más del 90 % de los profesores de primaria son mujeres.
Desde luego, no es solo lo que ocurre en clase.
Las redes sociales juegan un gran papel también.
No fue hace mucho
que se podía comprar una Teen Talk Barbie
que al tirar del cable,
decía cosas como,
"¿Alguna vez tendremos suficiente ropa?"
y "La clase de matemáticas es difícil".
Y solo hace unos años,
los principales mayoristas promocionaban camisetas para chicas jóvenes
en las que se leía cosas como, "Soy demasiado guapa para las matemáticas" o
"Soy demasiado bonita para hacer mis deberes, por eso mi hermano me los hace".
Y no nos olvidemos de los padres.
¡Oh! los padres.
Cuando los padres se preocupan por su propia habilidad matemática
y ayudan mucho a sus hijos con los deberes de matemáticas,
sus hijos aprenden menos matemáticas a lo largo del año escolar.
Como dijo uno de los padres,
"Juzgo la tarea de matemáticas de mi alumno de primer curso
en función de si es una tarea de solo una noche o de tres noches.
(Risas)
Cuando los adultos se preocupan por sus habilidades matemáticas,
se contagia a sus hijos
y les afecta, bloqueándose o superándose.
Así como podemos poner límites a otros,
podemos quitárselos.
Mi equipo de investigación y yo hemos demostrado
que al ayudar a los padres a hacer matemáticas divertidas con sus hijos,
en lugar de, solo cuentos para dormir o leer antes de acostarse,
hacen matemáticas a la hora de acostarse,
problemas divertidos que hacen con sus hijos por la noche,
no solo la actitud de los niños respecto a las matemáticas mejora,
sino que su propio rendimiento matemático a lo largo del año escolar,
mejora también.
Nuestro entorno importa.
Desde la clase, los padres hasta los medios,
puede marcar la diferencia entre quedarse atascado o progresar.
Pasando rápidamente del fútbol en la secundaria
a mi primer año en la universidad,
estaba en la secuencia de química para estudiantes de ciencias,
y desde luego, yo no me sentía pertenecer allí.
Aunque estudié para mi primer examen de mitad semestre,
pensaba que estaba preparada para hacerlo,
lo estropeé.
Literalmente tuve la peor nota de los 400 estudiantes.
Estaba convencida de que no iba a ser una estudiante de ciencias,
y que tal vez abandonaría la universidad.
Pero después cambié la manera de estudiar.
En lugar de estudiar a solas,
empecé estudiando con un grupo de amigos
quienes después de estudiar, cerraban los libros
e intentaban acertar las respuestas.
Aprendimos a practicar con estrés.
Si hubieran podido ver mi cerebro durante el examen del primer semestre,
probablemente habrían visto una respuesta de dolor neural
muy parecida a la ansiedad matemática que estudio.
Probablemente estaba allí también durante el estudio.
Pero cuando entré al fin,
mi mente estaba tranquila,
y conseguí una de las mejores calificaciones de toda la clase.
No solo era aprender el contenido;
sino a aprender a cómo superar mis limites cuando más lo necesitaba.
Lo que ocurre en nuestra cabeza importa,
y sabiendo esto,
podemos aprender a cómo prepararnos y preparar a otros para alcanzar el éxito,
no solo en el campo de juego o en la sala de reuniones
sino en la clase también.
Gracias
(Aplausos)